Brazil evokes images of women in skimpy
clothes on the beach or dancing to the
rhythm of Samba in the carnival parade
but beneath the thin layer of
open-mindedness worn by an urban
minority lies a significant conservative
constituency
with far-right president jabal sonaro in
power it has raised its voice
won over millions of angry voters by
lending his voice to their thoughts
conservative Brazilians have taken to
the streets against corruption but many
were afraid of speaking out against gay
marriage and gender policies because it
was not the thing to do with bolsonaro
they felt emboldened Francisco so I
helped elect leftist candidate luisi
nashu Lula the silver president in 2003
and re-elect him four years later he
felt betrayed by the corruption scandals
I decided to only vote for someone who
represents my values I love my family I
have a religion and I appreciate good
morals I'm not afraid to admit that I'm
a right winger this was parents still
support Lula because they believe he'll
help the poor but the shop owner and his
sister will vote for bolsonaro
I respect those who think differently
but I want to be respected as well as a
father I don't believe children should
be given the freedom to choose what
gender they identify with Lula was
running for a third presidential term is
trying to sweep voters like besora two
weeks before the runoff election he
wrote a letter to Evangelical Christians
who represent one-third of Brazil's
population
he promised to respect all religions as
he always has polls show six out of ten
support bolsonaro believing false
accusations that Lola Wants to close
down the churches
may win or lose the runoff presidential
election on October the 30th but his
right-wing allies have already secured a
majority in Congress
if Lula is elected president he will
have a hard time promoting a progressive
political agenda many hear dislike
monarchy and I give Al Jazeera Rio de
Janeiro